April 24th, 2025, President Trump just
released his first Armenian
Remembrance Day statement.
For four years Biden
used the word genocide.
Trump went back to
calling it a great tragedy.
But here's what really stunned me.
Armenia's own prime
minister also backed down.
In March, Nikol Pashinyan said
recognizing the Armenian
genocide isn't even a priority
for his government anymore.
Think about that for a second.
The country where it happened is
abandoning
recognition of its own genocide.
While every serious historian on earth
calls it genocide, the
politicians are sprinting
in the opposite direction.
This isn't just about
one historical event.
This is about watching a century-long
cover-up succeed in real time.
Turkey has spent 100 years and billions
of dollars constructing
an alternative reality
about 1915.
So to understand why even Armenia is
backing away from the
truth, you need to understand
exactly what the
alternative reality claims.
Because the gap between what Turkey says
happened and what
actually happened isn't just big.
It's a masterclass in how
to make genocide disappear.
Here's what Turkey's
government says happened in 1915.
This is their official position, taught
in Turkish schools and
promoted through international
lobbying.
Claim number one.
These were legitimate
wartime security measures.
Turkey says the Ottoman Empire was
fighting for survival
against Russia, Britain and France.
Armenian communities were actively
helping Russian forces,
engaging in armed rebellion
behind Ottoman lines.
So the government had no choice but to
temporarily relocate
Armenian populations away from war
zones.
But these relocations became tragic and
chaotic due to wartime
shortages, disease and breakdown
of government control.
Claim number two.
The death toll is massively exaggerated.
Turkish historians claim maybe 300,000
people died, mostly from
disease and starvation that
affected all Ottoman
subjects during the war.
Claim number three.
There was no systematic
plan and no genocidal intent.
Everything was just tragic wartime
displacement that got out of control.
And Erdoğan captured this perfectly in
2014 when he offered
condolences for "or shared
pain".
Shared pain.
Muslims and Christians
suffering equally from wartime chaos.
Now this narrative has serious
institutional backing.
Turkey spends millions every year on
lobbying firms,
university programs and think tanks
to promote this version globally.
When historians finally gained access to
Ottoman archives, German diplomatic
records and survivor
testimonies, every single
Turkish claim collapsed.
April 24th, 1915, 8pm, Constantinople.
Ottoman authorities begin mass arrests of
Armenian community leaders.
The Holocaust Memorial Museum confirms
240 arrests that first night.
In days this expanded to 2,345 total
arrests and deportations.
But here's the key detail.
These weren't soldiers or
suspected collaborators.
These were poets, doctors, lawyers,
teachers and clergymen.
People who lived 500
miles from any battlefield.
People who had never
seen a Russian soldier.
By May 27th, 1915, the Ottoman parliament
passed the temporary
law of deportation, making
Armenian removal
official government policy.
But here's what destroys the
emergency response narrative.
The Committee of Union and Progress, the
ruling party, had been
planning this since March
1915.
First arrest community leaders, then pass
legal framework, finally
systematic implementation
across the empire.
That's not panicked wartime response
That's the
choreography of planned genocide.
Now about those casualty figures.
Turkey claims 300,000 deaths
from general wartime conditions.
Historians using cross-verification from
multiple archives place the
death toll between 600,000
and 1.5 million.
But here's the crucial difference.
Even the conservative estimates represent
systematic extermination
of a specific population,
not general wartime mortality.
And we know this because historians found
something extraordinary.
The perpetrators had
documented their own genocide.
The Turkish denial narrative worked for
decades, primarily because
Ottoman archives remained
restricted.
But when historians finally gained access
and started
authenticating documents, they
uncovered something devastating.
The Ottoman government had written down
their genocidal intent.
Taner Akçam at Clark University holds
the world's only
endowed chair specifically in
Armenian genocide studies.
For two decades he's been using forensic
techniques to
authenticate Ottoman documents
that Turkey claimed were forgeries.
In 2018 his authentication work produced
what he calls "smoking gun evidence".
These aren't historians
making interpretations.
June 1915 telegram from Dr.
Sakir to regional governors.
Are the Armenians being dispatched from
there being liquidated?
Answer quickly.
Liquidated.
Not relocated.
Not protected.
The authenticated Bahaettin Şakir letters
are even more explicit.
"The Committee of Union and Progress has
decided to annihilate all
of Armenians living within
Turkey."
Annihilate all of Armenians?
That's genocidal intent in
the planners' own handwriting.
Interior Minister Talat Pasha's orders
explicitly discussed the
elimination of Armenians as
a political factor.
When government officials write about
liquidating, annihilating and
eliminating entire populations,
the intent debate is over.
This is why the International Association
of Genocide Scholars
unanimously recognized
the Armenian genocide.
Why 126 Holocaust historians signed
recognition statements?
Turkish claim one.
These were legitimate
security relocations.
If that were true, explain this.
Why relocate Armenian grandmothers and
disabled children into the Syrian desert?
What military threat did they pose?
Why destroy Armenian churches and schools
in areas that never saw combat?
Why forbid people from taking food during
temporary relocations
if the goal was their
survival?
Stanford historian Bert Patenaude states
that there's near
consensus among scholars who
study genocide that this was systematic
extermination, not security policy.
Turkish claim two.
Armenian collaboration forced our hand.
Even if some Armenians served with
Russian forces, which some did,
collective punishment
of entire populations violates every
principle of civilized warfare.
This logic would justify exterminating
all German-Americans
during World War I, or all
Japanese-Americans during World War II.
Actually, the US did intern
Japanese-Americans, and
later recognized that was wrong.
But internment isn't
systematic extermination.
The vast majority of
Japanese-Americans survived the war.
Ottoman Armenians did not.
Turkish claim three.
Death tolls are Armenian propaganda.
Historians don't rely on
Armenian sources alone.
They use systematic cross-verification
from multiple independent archives.
German diplomatic files, Austrian embassy
reports, American
missionary records, French
consular documentation, British
intelligence observations.
These countries were fighting
each other during World War I.
They had no reason to coordinate
propaganda about Armenian deaths.
This also cross-referenced pre-war
Ottoman census data with
postwar population surveys
to track demographic changes.
When multiple independent methodologies
converge on death tolls
exceeding 600,000, that's
systematic extermination.
Turkish claim four.
No genocidal intent existed.
This claim died when historians
authenticated the Ottoman documents.
When government telegrams ask if
Armenians are being liquidated.
When party correspondents discuss
annihilating entire
populations, intent isn't just proven,
it's explicit.
You don't accidentally plan
empire-wide extermination.
You don't accidentally
destroy an entire civilization.
So if the evidence is so overwhelming, if
every genocide
research institution agrees,
why are politicians
backing away from recognition?
Because Turkey has weaponized
the denial as foreign policy.
They've created a three-part system that
makes denial profitable
for other governments.
Part one, military leverage.
For decades, Turkey's NATO membership
gave them veto power over Allied
recognition efforts.
Countries needed Turkish bases, Turkish
cooperation in Middle
Eastern conflicts, Turkish support
for regional operations.
When Germany recognized the genocide in
2016, Turkey threatened
to withdraw cooperation
on Syrian refugees and NATO missions.
Part two, energy politics.
Turkey controls the pipeline system
carrying oil and gas
from Central Asia to Europe.
Countries wanting energy security think
twice about angering Turkey.
Israel gets 30% of its oil through the
Azerbaijan-Turkey pipeline.
That's why a country founded by genocide
survivors has been careful about Armenian
genocide recognition.
Part three, academic
and economic pressure.
Turkey funds university programs,
lobbying firms and think tanks that
promote their narrative
internationally.
When scholars challenge denial, Turkey
restricts archive access, cancels
academic partnerships,
applies diplomatic pressure.
This is how you institutionalize denial,
despite overwhelming contrary evidence.
Something shifted around 2016 when
Turkey's strategic value declined.
They bought Russian weapons, clashed with
NATO allies, moved
towards authoritarianism.
Germany broke ranks.
The Netherlands followed.
Biden made the breakthrough.
But Trump's 2025 about-face shows how
quickly recognition
disappears when administrations
change priorities.
And Armenia, abandoning
recognition of its own genocide?
That's realpolitik,
trumping historical truth.
This case reveals something disturbing
about how historical
truth works in practice.
Evidence doesn't
automatically translate into recognition.
Historical truth
requires political protection.
When Raphael Lemkin coined genocide in
1944, he explicitly cited
the Armenian case as why
such a legal concept was necessary.
But legal definitions mean nothing
without institutions
committed to maintaining them.
Today we have more evidence than ever.
Forensic authentication, international
scholarly consensus, the
perpetrator's own documents.
Yet political recognition is retreating
because strategic interests
override documented facts.
This teaches us that
historical truth is fragile.
It needs constant defense against
organized campaigns
that profit from denial.
If overwhelming evidence isn't enough to
secure recognition, then
historical truth depends
entirely on political will.
And when political will evaporates, even
the most documented
genocide can be bargained
away.
The Armenian genocide proves that you can
successfully deny
historical truth for a century
if you have enough
leverage and commitment.
Turkey's denial campaign has convinced
politicians worldwide to
trade historical accuracy for
diplomatic convenience.
But they can't change the evidence.
Every major genocide research institution
recognizes this as a genocide.
The forensic proof is overwhelming.
The next time you hear politicians use
euphemisms like tragic events
instead of genocide, remember
this.
They're choosing strategic convenience
over documented truth.
The historians have done their job.
The evidence is overwhelming.
The politicians are the ones failing.
Historical truth needs defenders.
Because if documented genocide can be
bargained away, then
historical truth depends on people
who refuse to let it happen.